foreign
say the problem is of epic proportions
all the warning signs were there but
they were ignored for decades the alarm
Bells really went off this year
hopefully not too late the Colorado
River the direct Lifeline for more than
42 million people and indirectly for
tens of millions more is in Peril it's
really bad right now and it's only
supposed to get worse next year we
um experts decision makers we've known
for for decades that there is this
Challenge on the Colorado River we've
known that we take more water out of the
system and the river can actually Supply
it we've known that
in the Western United States water is
the new gold the most sought after
commodity for States like Utah and
Wyoming for Arizona California for
Nevada New Mexico and Colorado water or
the like of it has become a huge problem
the same goes for dozens of Native
American tribes and communities of
indigenous people all face harsh water
cutbacks and tremendous challenges in
the future things are so bad the federal
government stepped in
Washington DC the department of interior
and its Federal Bureau of Reclamation in
an audio only press conference a sound
assessment of what is now slacked a
drought or Water Crisis and of what has
become a top priority for the White
House the prolonged drought afflicting
the West is one of the most significant
challenges facing our communities in our
country right now almost 93 percent of
the western United States is
experiencing drought or abnormally dry
conditions with more than 70 percent of
the western United States experiencing
severe or extreme drought conditions
those prolonged drought conditions
manifest even in the Rocky Mountains
global warming and climate change make
for very mild Winters that don't produce
enough snowmelt anymore for the Colorado
River to carry Downstream into Lake
Powell Lake Mead or beyond the Colorado
River Basin is in its 23rd year of a
historic drought
both Lake Powell and Lake Mead the two
largest reservoirs in the United States
are at historically low levels with
combined storage of 28 of their capacity
the system is approaching a Tipping
Point and without action we cannot
protect the system in the millions of
Americans who rely on this critical
resource
we're meeting with Christian gerlock a
community activist and Senior
representative of National Environmental
organization the Sierra Club Christian
wants to show us a place called Echo Bay
within what is known as Lake Mead
National recreational area just a few
miles east of Las Vegas hardly anybody
ever comes really to Echo Bay
unfortunately it was a very popular spot
so popular in fact it had an airport but
as you can see the water levels dropping
so dramatically it's affected the
economy of the area there are not people
coming out to visit and recreate as much
here in Echo Bay Echo Bay is not the
only spot falling victim to
unprecedented and record low water
levels of Lake Mead
from where the water stood in 2008 Mead
visitors now must drive almost a
kilometer farther until they can launch
their boats besides there's only one
boat ramp left
years ago there were 12. the marina
wants a bustling hot spot for boaters
and water sport enthusiasts is more
mostly empty parking spaces than ever
before at Lake Mead created by the
Hoover Dam one can see end experience
what it means when experts say the
system is at a Tipping Point I would be
concerned I mean
seems lower than average and I think
global warming has something going on
with it Christina Taub flight attendant
from Germany also visits Hoover Dam
she's alarmed by what she observed I
think the Belgium rang long time ago and
is it should keep on ringing and
something has to be done about it
absolutely it is very dangerously low
and we actually
part of a flight crew so we flew over a
few days ago and just to see it also
from above from 40 000 feet I can show
you pictures it's unbelievable
meets water level shranked by a whopping
150 plus feet in the last 40 years
an ever-growing so-called white bathtub
ring here and at other reservoirs will
have devastating effects for all U.S
states in the lower Colorado River basin
for tens of millions of people and
hundreds of thousands of businesses in
Nevada Arizona California and even in
Mexico the impacts we're seeing from
climate change are are I think you know
most of what we are more
um are happening quicker than we would
have expected and things the impacts of
um snowpack translating into photos in
the river are being
impacted by climate change things like
soil moisture temperatures
evapotranspiration all these little
mechanisms all these little components
to the hydrologic cycle here in the west
are being tweaked by climate change
we're on track to see additional drops
in the water levels to the point to
where it's scary we may face what is
called Deadpool where water will not
even flow out of Lake Mead further down
the Colorado River system
oh
no shortage of water in so-called Sin
City the expansive water fountain
display in front of Las Vegas iconic
Hotel Bellagio is just one example what
a waste not so fast Las Vegas Boom Town
and self-declared entertainment capital
of the world is in fact top of the line
when it comes to water recycling
preservation and conservation
so places like Las Vegas
have actually done amazing efforts in
terms of water conservation if every
city that relied on Colorado River water
has would do what Las Vegas has done our
cities would be in a much better spot
Las Vegas has really been a leader when
it comes to water conservation so things
like the pools you're looking at
um like the the big fountains in front
of the Bellagio that's recycled water
that's not potable water
in Las Vegas pictures like this
sprinklers irrigating golf courses or
public parks won't make for a lot of
fuss all water used is recycled reused
over and over again in the city's
suburbs homeowners rip out the grass in
their front and backyards and replace it
with gravel and fake grass throughout
the city's so-called non-functional turf
grass is banned now
most areas of turf that require a lot of
irrigation have been replaced the
Southern Nevada Water Authority has
taken tremendous steps toward reducing
the water usage in the past 20 years the
state of Nevada has seen tremendous
growth in the Las Vegas Valley but we've
actually seen a decrease in our water
usage thanks to programs that help
people take out their water thirsty
lawns
that's good news of course and those
measures are critically important
however they won't make a difference big
enough to create change on a larger
scale needed to prevent even worse
drought and water conditions in the
future we do need to make hard cuts that
that's the the fundamental Solution on
the Colorado River is we have to use
less water
and
you know the scale of how much we need
to use less is millions of acre feet so
you know the Colorado River on average
in the last 20 years is supplied like 13
to 14 million acre feet per year 13 to
14 million acre feet you know the Bureau
of Reclamation who manages the system is
telling us we need to cut two to four
million acre feet so that's like 15 to
30 percent of how much water we use on
the common nerve needs to be cut
immediately
so that's a that's a lot of water that's
a big scale
experts want that only unprecedented big
scale water use reductions strict water
conservation and ultimately the
decarbonization of our economies will
secure the Colorado River as a life
source for tens of millions of people
and for hundreds of thousands of
businesses we've got to decarbonize our
economies we've got to address the
situation of the carbon cycle which is
intricately linked to the natural water
cycle there is tremendous amounts more
carbon in the atmosphere than there was
uh several decades ago and that Trend
continues on and as we see that we will
see additional heat waves we will see uh
these additional heat Urban island
effect in Suburban areas where we do
have more asphalt when it rains
especially here in Las Vegas a lot of
asphalt
it funnels the water towards Lake Mead
but a lot of it is lost due to
evaporation and no longer penetrates the
water table so it's all an
interconnected system and we've got to
take a look at how our developed Society
is currently operating uh to make those
changes
making those perhaps painful but
strongly needed changes is not a can do
any longer but a must-do experts say
otherwise the mighty Colorado River is
feared to become not much more than a
public rather sooner than later
all right